on va se voir qu'est-ce que des cultures
cheddar attention qu est ce qu est le
clip ton général est le grand gagnant
devra désigner la personne parce que
c'est le test des miss qui ont fait pire
le grand gagnant devra désigner la
personne qui sera déguisé en geneviève
de fontenay jusqu'à la fin de l'émission
théo ça peut être toi pourquoi pas tout
le monde tout le monde joue même
pagaille addiction c'est vraiment les
questions qui ont été posées aux miss à
chaque fois je vous posais une question
vous avez trois secondes pour répondre
si j'envoie un triché il sera radié à
vie de tous les jours eh bien il faut
écrire non non et non par les éviter
bébés naissent là attention quelle est
la capitale de la suisse indique sa
salle dire oui avec ce qu'est ce que je
vais bien ce qu'il te parce que j'ai
ouvert aux barres et fatima la berne
berne comme merde mais les fans non ça
c'est stéphane bern la capitale ou non
en berne est sûre c'est stéphane bern
houben la capitale de la suisse très
bonne réponse à côté
si sa remue petit les cosaques à saly
est encore bien trop à quel est le nom
du joueur de football qui a été l'objet
du plus gros transfert entre deux clubs
en 2017 boli en 93 neymar a pas mal quel
est le nom du premier ministre français
a dans philippe way à traduire en
anglais je vais dîner au restaurant and
going to comment tu te la pètes n'a rien
dit nécessaire par cyril ah oui c'est
bon série lattois dans quel pays aura
lieu la prochaine coupe du monde de
football 2018 c'est une question pour
devenir miss alors série est ce que tu
as envie de venir me dit bon ça passe et
pas tout à fait mon truc en fait les le
foot c'est pas le truc ni les miss né le
6 avril tu peux retourner dans ses
cartons à nous sébastien ciré bah c'est
pas grave c'est qu'ils coûtent inquiète
pas vous laisser rue simonds syrie
attention puis il ya les le taux de
chômage de la population active en
france
à biot % près 9.8 9.5 et sachez qu'à la
fin de cette émission il sera douce on
dit qu'une audi d'une baleine qu'elle
chante ou qu'elles crient chantent
oui traduire en français m twenty years
old male of miss france quand c'est pour
s 21 ans et j'aime me faire un nom
la capitale de la suisse et la vie
zurich chanteuse ils sont combien
d'années tout de suite isabelle sénégal
retourne toi chien bars louches qui
avait percuté déguisant geneviève bon
moi ça sera ton sur ton
j'avais prévu une fois c'est pas que ces
tables saint-mathieu franchement avant
tout physique c'est qu'on peut prévenir
15 fois que tu veux mais butelle mouko
mais qu'est ce qu'ils n'ont pas résisté
lokéo web inquiétez pas question pour
participer à une course automobile c'est
votre rêve en personne au bout du 12e
tour vous doublez la voiture qui se
situe en deuxième position et vous
terminez la course à la même place
oui à quelle place êtes vous arrivé à la
course ma deuxième
bravo bravo et pas plus con qu'il en a
l'air bagram
vraiment les questions des miss
attentions auxquelles année paris
organisera tels les jeux olympiques de
2024 web assez bon calme toi tu
redescends quels partis américains
remporté les élections américaines en
2000 en 2016
magali magali agali à parts égales mais
ils ont perdu en france il république un
républicain qu'elle a répété la question
basque usa gb c'est direct ils ont
éliminé à théo et de l'homme voilà alors
attention quelle région d'espagne a fait
l'actualité ces dernières semaines en
réclamant son indépendance
ils voient qu'ils savent pouvoir balla
catalogue oui bah c'est bon et au non
mais dis donc
sa mort est un peu quel nom usuel d'un
terrain de tennis a failli qui joue très
bien oui ils sont maintenant on a joué
ensemble deux fois adressé à toi non
et quoique oury bah pour est d'accord
oui on avait sauté série à
on se calme
ça va moins ça va mal se terminer
vous savez on comprend mieux à présent
au froissement alors je vous dirai pas
sur vous dire la vérité 1 c'est comme ma
soeur et deux maximes je laime d'amour
il dit c'est un jeu lui prouve tous les
jours
glenda moi et je sais qu'il est très
amoureuse qui dit oui c'est jamais au
grand jamais je ne me mettrais entre les
deux on peut vous dire eh ouais les gars
et je suis en train de voir ça les
embête un peu tu te pètes entre les deux
méthodes vous le savez très bien que ce
n'est pas ma came ça n'est pas mon
délire voilà et jusqu'à combien 3 vous
êtes un petit peu prix aussi oui bah oui
mais bon quand même vous sur un dossier
peu contre l'émission là-bas ça il ya un
truc à la question pour vous à la tête
de quel pays durement touché par la
crise économique
alexis tsipras ce at il été élu en
septembre 2015 alors la manière dont il
m'a fait tomber
la grève a aussi peut-être le shonan ont
tant fait pour moi un peu quel dommage
devrait bientôt miss france non pas du
tout parce qu'elle me disait en mai
pascale et miss monde s'en fout d'être
mise comme ça on va pas la garde aux
mauvais temps le violent capital actuel
a été physiquement coupé en deux de 61
89 castel moissac a répondu je répondu à
quelques happy talhouët berlin berlin
exactement oui les cherry hill est pas
un postillon ce jeu et chier allez on
arrête
la récipiendaire
bon oui c'est ça oui peu des rennais
geneviève non mais vous n'avez pas gagné
non mais bouge pour moi c'était au cac
gagne oui non si c'était ok pour moi
théo qui veut tuer en jeunes de fontenay
pour la deuxième partie de l'émission
mamie non basi sa désole matthieu ce
soit